[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about episode 131 of
Dragon Ball super which is the final
episode at this point in time and we
will be looking at what this episode
told us about what's going to happen
next in the story now even though some
sources have been reporting it we don't
have a new series confirmed at this time
however we do know that the Dragon Ball
super movie that is coming out in
December of 2018 is a continuation of
the Dragon Ball super story so this is
definitely not the end in fact there
were multiple blatant clues in episode
131 that the adventure will continue
near the end of the episode the narrator
even says when a new unknown powerful
enemy appears Goku and his friends
adventures will begin again until then a
brief parting see you all again it
really can't be more clear that the
writers of super don't plan on ending
the story here so in this video we will
be looking at what is likely to happen
next in Dragon Ball super including the
upcoming movie and beyond I think that
episode 131 gave us a bunch of very
interesting hints for what direction the
story will follow in the future and I
think the wish itself the wish made by
Android 17 with the super Dragon Balls
is a major clue for what happens next if
you enjoyed these types of videos be
sure to leave a like to let me know
there is a lot more Dragon Ball super
content coming up right here at anime
uproars so if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell and if you want to
discuss anime theories and what happens
next in Dragon Ball super be sure to
check us out on Twitter and Instagram
at anime uproar if you've been following
this channel for a while you know that
I've been saying from the very beginning
that at the end of the tournament of
power all of the universes that were
erased will be brought back just looking
at the Dragon Ball franchise and how
often the Dragon Balls have been used to
wish characters back from the dead I
knew that there was no way that popular
characters like members of the
universe 16 would disappear forever I
knew that they would be back it was just
a matter of how exactly it would happen
in the end Android 17 was the last man
standing after fries and Goku worked
together to knock jiren out and by the
way how crazy was it to see Goku and
Frieza fighting together after all this
time that hit me right in the childhood
anyway when he was asked to make the
wish Android 17 said the following
please restore all of the universes that
were erased and this is according to the
official crunchyroll translation and
crunchyroll is an official streaming
service that works together with toys so
this is not a fansub or anything like
that so the important thing about this
wish is that Android 17 did not say
restore all the universes that were
erased during the tournament of power
instead he said restore all of the
universes that were erased period he
didn't specify a time frame and if you
think back to earlier in the series we
learned that there were once 18
universes but six of them were erased by
Zeno and this happened before the
tournament was even announced with the
way Android 17 phrased his wish without
specifying a time it is logical to
assume that restore all of the universes
that were erased will include the six
universes that were erased earlier I've
always thought that doing this would be
an excellent idea because it opens up so
many different possibilities for the
story what is going on in these six
universes why were these specific six I
raised by Zeno in the first place are
they're powerful evil forces there that
made Zeno decide to erase them just like
future Zen I've decided to erase the
entire future timeline because of the
evil deeds of za masu if that's the case
and in these universes there is a
villain so powerful that the gods of
destruction and angels of those
universes couldn't deal with him so Zeno
had to straight-up erase him now that
Goku Vegeta and everyone else is so much
stronger after the tournament of power
this opie villain from the erased
universes would make for the perfect new
challenge another crazy idea that I've
seen floating around in the comments on
my Dragon Ball super videos is that
maybe restoring all the universes that
were here a
we'll also apply to the future timeline
and so infinite sum a su could return to
threaten the existence of the multiverse
yet again personally I think that the
fact that they told us to expect a new
unknown powerful enemy means that it
won't be is imasu but it's still an
interesting thought after all future
zento being in the present timeline is
still an unresolved plot point can two
Omni Kings exist in the same timeline
for a long period of time without
something going wrong we'll have to wait
and see in the quick preview for the
Dragon Ball super movie that we've seen
so far we appear to see Goku getting
ready to fight another mysterious saying
and this saying has a powerful greenish
aura and yellowish eyes during this
teaser we also see the words a Saiyan
has no limits which again seems to imply
that the rival we see Goku fighting is a
Saiyan I say rival and not a villain
because if you look at the scene from
the teaser and you look at how Goku is
behaving it looks like he is training
Goku is getting ready to train and spar
with the Saiyan not fight to the death
or anything like that so it is very
possible that this saying isn't a
villain at all and the new unknown
villain could be someone completely
different
and in fact Goku might even team up with
this new Saiyan at some point in the
movie but whether he's a villain or not
who could this new say and be there are
many theories out there including yah
moshi the legendary Super Saiyan God and
the king of the universe 6 saying but
llamo she is supposed to be long dead so
unless he somehow became immortal and
has been hiding all this time without
being sensed by anyone the way to have
you Moshi in the movie is probably
through some sort of time travel as far
as the king of the universe 6 and goes
his power level should be nowhere near
Goku's at this point in time don't
forget that the universe 6 and didn't
even know about the Super Saiyan
transformation and if the king of the
universe 6 sands was so powerful as to
rival Goku then why wasn't he taking
part in the tournament I am certain that
Champa would have wanted the best
possible fighters on his team and if he
could get the other sands like Kaba kale
and khalifa to agree then why not the
king with the existence of
whole universe on the line and the super
Dragon Balls as the reward I am sure
that the king of the sands would have
agreed to participate if he had been
strong enough and this is where we come
back to the wish made by Android 17 in
episode 1 3 1 we know that Saiyans exist
in universe 7 and 6 because these are
twin universes so that makes sense but
do we know that Saenz don't exist in
other universes as well don't forget
that the yard rat race exists in both
universe 7 and universe - even though 7
and 2 are not twin universes so it is
possible that Saiyans exist in other
universes as well aside from 7 and 6 in
fact if the other six universes that
were erased earlier were revived by
Android 17 swish who's to say that there
aren't Saiyans in one of those universes
if those six universes were erased
because of some great evil and if there
are Saiyans in these universes would
contact with this evildoer then we can
easily see how some of these sayings
could have gotten incredibly strong by
trying to fight off this great evil for
many years before the six universes were
finally erased the fact that the
universes were erased would explain why
no one has seen these other sayings or
sensed their power and of course why
they weren't in the tournament itself
perhaps some of these sayings from the
six lost universes came to even rival
Goku's current power and now that all
the universes have been brought back
they will have to team up with Goku and
his friends to finally defeat the great
villain the new powerful unknown villain
whose evil deeds caused the six
universes to be erased in the first
place and I guess if you really love the
idea of your Moshi being in the movie
perhaps he went off to fight the unknown
villain in one of the six universes a
long time ago and was erased along with
them that means that um oh she wouldn't
age in the meantime and would still be
alive once the universe's are brought
back personally I really support this
theory that the other six erased
universes will now be brought back and
if that theory does turn out to be true
it would explain a few other plot points
from episode 131 as well at one point in
the episode we says that Zeno sama has
expectations that go
when his friends can change something if
Zeno erased the six universes because of
some great evil and that made him lose
faith in mortals then the next adventure
for Goku and Friends will be to right
the wrongs that happened within these
six universes and that is what Zeno is
expecting of them that is what the
tournament of power was a test for if
this does happen then the tournament arc
transitions very smoothly into the next
arc and despite the fact that Goku has
gotten so strong now since we still
haven't seen anyone from the other six
universe as the potential for even more
powerful villains and even greater
challenges is still there the other plot
point from episode 1 3-1 that the return
of the six other universes would solve
is Frieza becoming the Emperor of the
universe once again Frieza did an
incredible job during the tournament he
was crucial for the victory of universe
7 and as a reward he was revived by
Wiese but we know that Frieza isn't
going to become good now and apparently
he has re-established his army and is
determined to become the Emperor once
again so what does this mean
his fries are going to go and slaughter
millions of innocent people once again
in universe 7 and Goku and Friends are
just going to stand by and let it happen
I don't think this is likely and I don't
think Frieza being the major villain yet
again is a good idea at all however if
the other six universes are brought back
but they are in chaos because of the
great evil that caused them to be erased
in the first place then Frieza could
take his army there and fight against
the evildoers in those six universes
does this mean that Frieza would then
become a good guy not necessarily good
he would still be the same emperor bent
on conquest but perhaps in return for
fighting the chaos in the other six
universes he will be given the right to
rule over all of the territory that he
liberates from the villains there that
way Frieza is still up Emperor and a
conqueror but not necessarily a villain
and those are my thoughts on what will
happen next in the story of Dragon Ball
super
I am definitely standing behind the
theory that there are now 18 universes
after Android 17 swish because I just
think
would be such a cool plot twist with so
many new possibilities for the future
but this is not yet confirmed it is just
a theory at this point so please let me
know what you guys think down below what
is going to happen next
who is the new Saiyan in the Dragon Ball
super movie are all 18 universes back
now or are there still only 12 let me
know down in the comments if you enjoyed
this video want to see more be sure to
leave a like to let me know if you are
new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
and we are now posting daily anime
content on Twitter and Instagram so be
sure to follow us at anime uproar as
always thank you all so much for
watching and until next time see our
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]